(audience cheering)
(jazz music)
(drums)
Thank you so much!
Thank you very much!
Welcome to Comic Con!
(audience cheering)
We have an amazing show for you tonight.
This is our third year.
[Andy] Yes.
Here.
Third year here.
Let me start by promising that tonight
there will be no Ed Sheeran cameo.
That is my promise to you.
(audience cheering)
(laughs)
'Course I'm talking about Game of Thrones.
Game of Thrones returned on Sunday.
Fans were upset that there was a cameo by Ed Sheeran.
Yes!
Yes, even worse, next week's episode of Game of Thrones
is called The Biebering.
(audience laughs)
That's not a good sign.
(audience cheers)
As you know, I was at Comic Con last year
and last year there were a bunch of movies
about a dreary dystopian future.
Yeah.
Turns out they were documentaries.
(audience laughs)
That's one--
(audience cheers)
No!
(laughs)
Don't applaud that one, we're really screwed right now.
(audience laughs)
They're like (laughs).
(groans)
Lots of special events taking place in honor of Comic Con.
Yesterday at the San Diego library
there was a Quidditch tournament.
Yeah!
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
Yes! Yes!
And trust me, when a bunch of adults get together
to play Quidditch, there are no winners.
(audience laughs)
I like that there were people,
I'm sorry, there was a whole section that was so happy.
(laughs)
Conan likes Quidditch!
Why would he say it?
Right now they're hiding their brooms.
[Conan] I know.
Sliding them under.
It's expensive to be here.
Isn't it expensive?
It is expensive.
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
This is an interesting fact,
the average cost to attend Comic Con is $1,603.
Yeah.
Which, coincidentally, is the exact amount of money
that Transformers took in last weekend.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheering)
I just turned into a Chevrolet right there.
Yeah.
By the way, I gotta mention this, in the new Transformers 5,
they open with the Transformers in the distant past.
I don't know if you saw that.
Yeah, distant past.
Unfortunately, not far enough in the past to stop
the meeting where they decided to make Transformers 5.
(audience laughs)
It was the only flaw.
(audience cheering)